(Transcrito por TurboScribe. Atualize para Ilimitado para remover esta mensagem.) Nesta aula, nós vamos falar sobre as ferramentas
de avaliação online de um imóvel e sobre
como obter informações de um ocupante.
A primeira verificação que qualquer interessado em participar
de um leilão de um imóvel deve fazer
é verificar o valor de mercado daquele imóvel.
Vamos entender.
Eu falei na aula anterior que existe um
preço da primeira praça e um preço da
segunda praça, tanto para o leilão judicial quanto
para o leilão extrajudicial.
Eu falei que no leilão judicial, a primeira
praça é calculada de acordo com o laudo
de avaliação judicial realizado sobre aquele imóvel.
E esse laudo que determina o valor de
mercado daquele imóvel que está indo a leilão.
E eu falei que no leilão extrajudicial, a
primeira praça vai ter o valor que o
próprio contrato de alienação fiduciária estipulou para o
imóvel caso acontecesse um leilão ou pelo valor
venal do ITBI.
O que for maior.
Só que a primeira verificação é realmente saber
se esses valores estão compatíveis com o valor
de mercado.
Veja, no leilão judicial, é bem mais fácil
você encontrar um leilão que realmente o valor
da primeira praça, o valor que foi encontrado
no laudo de avaliação judicial, é muito próximo
ao valor de mercado, um pouco acima ou
um pouco abaixo.
Mas no leilão extrajudicial, é comum que existam
imóveis que estão com um valor muito acima
do valor de mercado em primeira praça.
E depois isso vai refletir também num desconto
que vai ser oferecido em segunda praça de
dívidas mais encargos.
Então você tem que saber qual é o
valor de mercado daquele imóvel que você está
interessado em arrematar.
Isso para um leilão que você participe como
forma de investimento é importantíssimo.
Porque você só vai saber se existe viabilidade
financeira naquele leilão, ou seja, se aquele leilão
vai te dar lucro ou não, se você
avaliar qual é o valor de mercado daquele
imóvel.
Você não pode delegar isso aí pra ninguém,
porque é o seu dinheiro que está em
risco, é o dinheiro dos seus investimentos, e
você tem que cuidar com muita atenção disso.
Mas a boa notícia disso tudo, é que
é muito fácil hoje em dia a gente
saber qual é o valor de mercado de
um imóvel.
Por quê?
Porque hoje em dia, basicamente, todo mundo que
vai vender um imóvel faz anúncio desse imóvel
na internet.
Não existe forma mais eficaz de entregar um
anúncio para as pessoas e de atingir o
máximo de pessoas interessadas do que colocar um
anúncio de um imóvel na internet.
Então você vai utilizar esses sites que as
pessoas usam para anunciar, para fazer buscas parecidas
com o imóvel que você está interessado em
arrematar.
É possível que você encontre no mesmo edifício,
se for um imóvel dentro de um condomínio,
um apartamento, imóveis com a mesma planta, mesma
metragem, tudo igual, sendo vendidos naquele condomínio.
E você vai saber qual é o valor
que as pessoas estão pedindo.
Mas não fique só com imóveis de um
condomínio especificamente, fique com imóveis da região.
Todos esses sites, eles possuem um campo para
filtrar.
Então você vai filtrar de acordo com a
metragem do imóvel, número de quartos, vagas de
garagem, quais são as características daquele imóvel que
podem acrescentar um valor.
Exemplo, se for um apartamento num condomínio novo,
com piscina, sauna, churrasqueira, isso tudo tem um
valor agregado.
Você não pode comparar esse apartamento com outro
apartamento de um prédio que não tenha infraestrutura
nenhuma.
Isso não faz o menor sentido.
As pessoas hoje em dia buscam o máximo
de facilidade que elas podem ter dentro de
um condomínio.
Então isso tudo, por óbvio, é muito vantajoso.
Faça ali na mesma região, busca de imóveis
parecidos com o imóvel que você quer arrematar.
Principalmente de metragem e de áreas de lazer
de um condomínio.
Isso vai te dar um norte do valor
médio que as pessoas estão cobrando.
E é com esse valor médio de mercado
que você vai analisar se você participa ou
não de um leilão.
Porque se a sua finalidade for a finalidade
de investimento, realmente você precisa pegar um imóvel
com uma margem boa de diferença do valor
de mercado.
Para que você tenha uma margem boa de
desconto para oferecer na venda.
Para que você possa calcular tudo aquilo que
você vai gastar na aquisição daquele imóvel.
Na manutenção daquele imóvel até a venda.
E ainda assim fique com um bom lucro.
Essa é a forma mais eficaz de você
encontrar o valor médio de mercado.
Mas você também deve recorrer a profissionais habilitados
para venda de imóvel.
Quem são esses profissionais?
Esses profissionais são os corretores de imóveis.
Corretores são grandes aliados de qualquer pessoa que
participe de mercado imobiliário.
Por quê?
Primeiro que os corretores têm uma rede de
relacionamento formada.
Então os corretores têm contato com bastante gente.
Eles sabem qual é o prazo que está
sendo vendido um imóvel naquela determinada região.
Qual é o valor médio que está sendo
vendido.
Qual é o estado de conservação dos imóveis
que estão sendo vendidos.
Isso tudo é muito importante.
Então você pode também utilizar o contato direto
com corretores daquela região.
Como você vai fazer isso?
Através do Google.
Pelo Google identifique imobiliários daquela região e entre
em contato por telefone.
Fale sua história.
Fale que você está interessado em arrematar um
apartamento tal.
Depois até fale que vai entregar aqueles corretores
o seu apartamento para venda.
Porque isso é sempre um ânimo numa troca
de informações.
Então esse corretor com certeza vai te ajudar.
Não entre em um leilão sem saber qual
é o valor real de mercado daquele imóvel.
Não confie no valor que o leiloeiro coloca
em seu site em primeira praça e em
segunda praça.
Faça sua própria busca.
Lembre é o seu dinheiro que está em
jogo.
É o seu investimento.
Só depende de você fazer uma boa arrematação.
Existe também outra dúvida muito comum.
Que é sobre como eu vou saber o
estado de conservação do imóvel que eu quero
arrematar.
Quando é feito um laudo de avaliação e
um leilão judicial.
Geralmente o juiz pode determinar que esse laudo
seja realizado por um perito judicial.
Esse perito na maioria dos casos são arquitetos
ou engenheiros.
Então é normal que num leilão judicial o
próprio laudo de avaliação ele traga fotos internas
do imóvel.
E dessa forma você vai saber perfeitamente qual
é o estado de conservação daquele imóvel.
Agora existem laudos realizados por oficiais de justiça
que são laudos bem mais simples.
A gente vai estudar a diferenciação dos dois
modelos no módulo 3 que é de leilão
judicial.
E também existe o leilão excrujudicial que não
tem esse laudo de avaliação.
Exatamente porque o próprio contrato já estipulou um
valor para caso acontecesse um leilão.
Então nesses casos você vai precisar realmente averiguar
qual é o estado de conservação de um
imóvel.
Como é que você vai fazer isso?
A forma mais eficaz de fazer esse levantamento
do estado de conservação de um imóvel é
entrar em contato com pessoas que possam te
passar essas informações.
Quem?
Se for um imóvel dentro de um condomínio,
com certeza porteiro, zelador, síndico vão te passar
essas informações porque esses profissionais têm informação completa
do que se passa no dia a dia
de um condomínio.
Então eles sabem qual foi o imóvel que
passou por uma reforma, qual é o imóvel
que não passa por uma reforma mais tempo.
Eles com alguma constância podem ter acesso a
alguma parte do imóvel e assim eles podem
te passar alguma informação.
Eu sempre recorro a esse método quando eu
não tenho informações de um laudo de avaliação
completo.
E como é que eu faço isso?
Você tem duas formas de fazer isso.
Você pode ir pessoalmente ao local e conversar
com essas pessoas ou você pode fazer isso
de forma remota, que é a forma que
eu mais gosto de utilizar.
Eu descubro o telefone de um condomínio, por
exemplo, entro em contato, falo que eu sou
interessada no leilão do imóvel tal, que vai
acontecer no dia tal e peço maiores informações.
Geralmente as pessoas são muito solícitas, até porque
quando tem um devedor dentro de um condomínio
é interesse do próprio condomínio tirar aquele devedor
de lá.
Porque um devedor de condomínio causa transtorno para
todos os moradores daquele condomínio.
Então tudo que um síndico mais quer é
acabar com todos os devedores daquele condomínio.
É realmente que aqueles devedores se mudem de
lá e vão morar em outro lugar.
Então, em geral, é muito tranquilo de conseguir
esse tipo de informação.
Então eu localizo o telefone no Google, ligo
e peço essas informações.
Nessa mesma ligação eu também peço informações sobre
a ocupação do imóvel.
Lembra que a gente já falou aqui no
curso que muitas vezes o edital coloca que
o imóvel está ocupado?
Mas que na prática o imóvel já foi
desocupado?
Como é que você vai fazer isso?
Exatamente nessa sua pesquisa de campo.
Ou comparecendo pessoalmente, ou fazendo isso por telefone.
Já peça para a pessoa te informar se
tem alguém morando ou não.
E aqui uma dica.
Você sabe o nome do proprietário daquele imóvel.
Por que você sabe?
Porque essa informação está na matrícula do imóvel
e porque essa informação está no edital do
imóvel.
Então pode ser que se você perguntar de
forma vaga, o profissional que está do outro
lado, um porteiro por exemplo, ele fique meio
receoso porque ele não sabe com o que
ele está falando.
Afinal de contas ele não está te vendo
no telefone.
Então ao invés de perguntar se o imóvel
está ocupado ou não, você pergunta diretamente pelo
nome do proprietário.
Vamos supor aqui que o nome do proprietário
seja Daniel.
Nessa mesma ligação aproveite e pergunte.
Uma informação por favor.
O Daniel ainda mora no apartamento?
Ele ainda mora no imóvel?
E assim o porteiro vai se sentir mais
seguro para te passar essa informação.
Afinal de contas você sabe efetivamente o nome
do proprietário daquele apartamento.
E pode ser que ele te fale que
não.
Que quem está morando naquele apartamento é um
inquilino ou um parente do Daniel.
Qual a importância também de você saber qual
é o estado de ocupação daquele imóvel?
Você deve ficar de fora de todo e
qualquer imóvel que você saiba que existiu uma
invasão.
Isso é bem mais difícil de acontecer em
um condomínio.
Porque o condomínio tem sempre acesso rescrito e
dificilmente alguém vai invadir um apartamento ou uma
casa dentro de um condomínio exatamente pela dificuldade
de entrar naquele condomínio.
Mas pode ser que em casa de rua
isso seja mais comum.
Então tente sempre levantar e fique sempre de
fora se for uma invasão.
Se você tiver informação de quem está morando
lá é o proprietário, é a família do
proprietário, é um inquilino que tem um contrato
com aquele proprietário, tudo bem, você pode participar
sem qualquer problema.
Se você tiver informação de que aquele imóvel
foi invadido em algum momento ou quem está
morando lá é alguém que não tem a
menor relação com o proprietário, eu aconselho que
você fique de fora desses imóveis.
Por quê?
Porque existe a chamada uso capião.
E o uso capião é realmente a tomada
de uma propriedade daquilo que se tem posse
durante alguns anos.
E existem vários tipos de uso capião.
O objetivo do curso aqui não é passar
esse tipo de uso capião porque vocês não
vão ter utilidade prática disso.
O que vocês precisam saber na prática é
se deparou com a informação de que quem
está naquele imóvel não é o proprietário, não
é o inquilino que tem relação com aquele
proprietário, não é a família do proprietário que
aquele imóvel tem alguém morando dentro, que não
tem relação nenhuma com o proprietário, fique de
fora desse leilão, passe para o próximo leilão.
Sobre o estado de conservação de um imóvel,
se você não conseguir informação alguma sobre aquele
imóvel, se o imóvel passou ou não por
uma reforma, se não tiver fotos internas daquele
imóvel, recorra ao último caso que é analisar
qual é a idade daquele imóvel.
Pode ser que você não tenha informação nenhuma,
mas que você verifique que um prédio, por
exemplo, tem 10 anos, a chance daquele apartamento
estar muito deteriorado é praticamente nenhuma.
E se ele estiver deteriorado, vai precisar somente
de reforma estética, ou seja, uma pintura na
parede, trocar um piso, isso tudo tem um
valor muito pequeno perto de um valor que
você pode conseguir de desconto num leilão.
Então faça essa análise.
Se você não conseguir informação alguma sobre o
estado de conservação de um imóvel, veja na
matrícula do imóvel o ano de construção daquele
imóvel.
E aí analise uma pequena reforma que você
faria.
Como que você vai fazer isso?
Verifique a metragem de um imóvel.
Se for um imóvel de 70 m², vá
a um site de uma loja de material
de construção e veja qual é o preço
médio de um piso, um metro quadrado e
multiplique.
Às vezes você vai ver que para trocar
um piso inteiro de um apartamento, você vai
precisar de um pouco mais de 5 mil
reais.
E você pegou um imóvel com um percentual
de desconto de 50%.
Esses 5 mil reais não vão impactar no
seu lucro.
Ainda assim você vai continuar lucrando muito.
Mas sempre faça essa análise para você saber
qual é o lance máximo que você pode
ofertar no imóvel ou não.
Porque o lance máximo realmente vai ser calculado
com tudo aquilo que você vai gastar no
imóvel.
Na próxima aula a gente vai falar especificamente
sobre isso.
Por fim, eu também queria falar de uma
forma de consulta de dados das pessoas caso
você não consiga recorrer a nenhuma dessas formas
que eu falei anteriormente.
E aí são dados pessoais dessa pessoa.
Então se você ligou para um condomínio e
você queria saber qual era a idade de
um determinado proprietário porque você não se sinta
confortável para arrematar um imóvel de alguém muito
idoso e que nesse caso você não conseguiu
informação nenhuma e nem no processo, nem no
edital, em nenhum lugar nenhum tem a idade
dessa pessoa.
Você pode recorrer ao site consultefacil.com.br
Vou deixar o link na descrição aqui dessa
aula.
O site ele está aberto aqui no computador.
O site esse aqui que está na tela
ele foi criado para que empresas busquem informações
sobre os seus consumidores para saber se essa
empresa pode ou não conceder um crédito a
esse consumidor.
Numa pesquisa mais detalhada aqui você consegue saber
inclusive qual é a renda mensal daquela pessoa,
a data de nascimento, os telefones daquela pessoa,
basicamente todos os endereços que aquela pessoa já
morou.
Então é uma busca muito completa.
Você pode utilizar esse site também para sua
finalidade de busca de dados das pessoas envolvidas
em um leilão.
Como é que eu geralmente uso esse site
aqui?
Eu falei que a gente sempre vai ter
o CPF do proprietário porque essa informação vai
estar na matrícula e no edital do leilão.
Então se você quiser mais informações você pode
recorrer a um desses modelos de busca.
Eu utilizo sempre esse aqui, consulta super para
CPF.
Custa 25 reais.
Eu teria que comprar créditos aqui, porque nesse
momento eu só tenho 4 reais então eu
teria que completar.
E eu buscaria o CPF dessa pessoa.
Depois que você clicar aqui, caso você tenha
crédito, ele vai abrir uma tela para você
preencher o CPF.
Você vai preencher, vai colocar ok e ele
vai abrir todos os dados pessoais daquela pessoa.
Isso pode te ajudar muito em vários casos.
Inclusive você pode conseguir um telefone direto daquele
proprietário, daquele devedor.
É importante que você saiba que você deve
verificar o estado do imóvel, a ocupação daquele
imóvel, para que você se sinta seguro em
participar de um leilão.
Isso tudo vai te deixar muito mais tranquilo
para participar de um leilão porque efetivamente você
sabe todas as características do imóvel de quem
está morando.
É quase que um trabalho investigativo.
Use também a seu favor redes sociais.
Redes sociais podem te fornecer muitos dados, inclusive
com fotos internas.
É muito comum que as pessoas coloquem fotos
dentro de casa nas redes sociais.
Então você pode verificar através dessas fotos qual
o estado de conservação.
Recorra Facebook, Instagram, LinkedIn para descobrir dados profissionais
daquela pessoa, saber onde aquela pessoa trabalha.
Isso tudo vai te ajudar muito, isso tudo
vai te trazer segurança.
Faça realmente um trabalho de detetive.
Use sempre esse lado de busca para te
trazer segurança para que você possa se sentir
tranquilo ao realizar uma arrematação.